istanbul vom bosporus umarmt und von
über 14 millionen menschen bewohnt hier
trifft europa auch asien ein
schmelztiegel der kulturen und im moment
der treffpunkt für kunstinteressierte
die biennale trägt den titel two schluss
zu das bedeutet salzwasser ein
poetischer name für eine ausstellung die
entschieden politisch sein will kann das
gut gehen
hier zuerst erwarten mich bunte kurven
in 3d künstler karikieren unser stetiges
bestreben nach ökonomischen erfolg
daneben hat der libanese marwan 3 v.li
seine skulpturen platziert traurige
erinnerungen an seine kindheit in beton
gegossen
die venus and lumpen
ein fingerzeig auf die modernen
überflussgesellschaft politische kunst
die etwas will mahnen waren aufklärend
bei der jungen türkischen künstlerin us
lecce wushu wird es wirklich politisch
ein tabuthema in der türkei die arminia
in ihren arbeiten zeigt sie die
historische entwicklung dieser intensiv
roten farbe
diese war stets ein symbol für die
verbindung zwischen der türkischen und
armenischen kultur die buchmesse steht
für die grenze zwischen den beiden
ländern
nach dem völkermord gab es niemanden
mehr auf der türkischen seite der wusste
wie man zudem pigment stoff kommt dieses
wissen ging verloren
ich wollte zeigen wie sich die schöne
mit der farbe entfaltet und was wir das
türkische volk eigentlich verloren haben
diese rote farbe und die armenier als
armenierin möchte ich ihnen danken dafür
dass sie unsere geschichte erzählen us
lecce sagt als politische künstlerin
brauche sie die vergangenheit zum
kritisch über die gegenwart nachdenken
zu können
dabei hat sie ihr ganz eigenes system
entwickelt wie sie als künstlerin ohne
einschränkungen arbeiten kann
mutig und subversiv ich kreiere jeweils
eine erste schicht bei einem kunstwerk
eine oberfläche die der betrachter
einfach anschauen genießen kann
erst wenn man tiefer gehen will dann
wird man die politische komponente der
arbeit entdecken
das ist meine arbeitsweise und ich denke
dieses vorgehen ist wie ein schild das
mich vor schwierigkeiten schützt 36
standorte bespielt die biennale in der
ganzen stadt die aula einer griechischen
schule fungiert als salz verkrustetes
science fiction arena die an mehr als
todbringende gewalt denken lässt ein
indirekter verweis auf flüchtlings
routen im aufgeheizten raum wird von
einem gesunkenen salz boot erzählt dass
im jahr 2003 100 wieder auftaucht
daneben rahmen mit der düsteren realität
von heute listen mit namen von menschen
die von der polizei getötet wurden
beeindruckend je länger der kunst
marathon dauert desto mehr verliert die
biennale für mich an kontur
alles soll ein kunstort sein die
autogarage mit einer soundinstallation
vielleicht ist mein biennale pensum für
heute auch schon über erfüllt spätestens
in einer umfunktionierten boutique
dröhnt mir nur noch der kopf
ich muss raus aus dem biennale betrieb
draußen eine demonstration gegen erdogan
ich treffe den fotografen morath german
inmitten der arbeiter die hier
protestieren für bessere
arbeitsbedingungen und mehr
meinungsfreiheit
es war immer schon problematisch mit der
es gibt sie ihr schon bis zu einem
gewissen grad
aber du warst verfolgt wenn du dich
nicht an die vorgaben hält
du hast angegriffen oder gar getötet
sieht auch aus wie eine kunstaktion
feiner protest gegen ein übermächtiges
system wenn ich mich nicht widersetzen
würde würde ich in eine tiefe depression
fallen
aber wenn ich etwas tue und dokumentiere
was hier passiert die probleme werden
sich nicht in kurzer zeit lösen
vielleicht auch nicht nach langer zeit
aber ich fühle dass ich so etwas beitrag
speziell nach den gc protesten wurde ich
noch stärker zum dokumentaristen da habe
ich verstanden dass die realen
geschehnisse hier viel seltsamer sind
als jede fiktionale arbeit es je sein
können das politische klima im land ist
vergiftet
kurz vor den wahlen vom ersten november
auch wenn meine ersten eindrücke positiv
war die biennale hat die chance verpasst
neue horizonte zu eröffnen die 500.000
besucher werden meist verschont von
politischer dringlichkeit keine fragen
nach der trunkenen im salzwasser des
mittelmeers keine fragen nach den 25
millionen syrischen flüchtlingen im
eigenen land zu oft gibt es statt
politischer impulse nur wuchtige poesie